75 years ago a teenager's diary became
one of the most powerful accounts to
emerge from the second world war
of course the world would only learn
about anne frank's diary and daily life
under nazi occupation after her death
but what if she and others like her
could have shared their stories sooner
does that mean we would have a different
understanding of the war while it is
proceeding rather than afterwards
from her home in ukraine valeria
shashanok isn't keeping a traditional
diary instead like many people her age
she has a tick tock account and her
videos have gone viral
when you you follow somebody on tick
tock who's just a regular person like
anybody else is a regular person and
then the next day
their country has been invaded right and
their their daily life now is uh look at
me in this underground bunker uh look at
me in this empty
grocery store it makes the war
reel
shashanook's videos are both shocking
and familiar
a young life so entirely relatable here
in canada suddenly upended by war
her tick tock's now earning millions of
views around the world it's a remarkably
powerful set of testimonies that
everyday people are sharing i think it's
really important that these materials
are being published and consumed in the
middle of the conflict and not just
after it's all gone
a documentation via viral dance app it's
now an accounting of history being
broadcast in real time a young woman's
real life
playing out amid so much uncertainty
heather urex west global news calgary